hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing our match
between a poor Charles Murphy and Samuel
Standish Boden while Stanton is
preparing his endings and openings
Murphy has to deal with Stanton's
millions before he faces the the man
himself and this is a1 one of the games
that I decided to show you we already
checked out one game from this match was
a really enjoyable King's gambit game
but here it's the two Knights defense
really really enjoyable how it was
played in the old days and here we have
a line that you will not see today now
played in today's chair so it is very
interesting and some of you have been
saying in the comments that it's
actually Staunton not Staunton and I
have no idea why this would be so I've
never heard of this pronunciation before
so if any of you have any reference that
it's actually pronounced Staunton or
however that would be pronounced do
share and I will happily apply it now
getting back to the game morphe opens
with E 4 with E 5 as we already
mentioned it will be the two Knights
defense 96 Bishop to c4 the Italian game
is on the board and Knight to f6 so the
two Knights defense and of course Knight
to g5 going straight for the f7 for the
five blacks only good response
it captures with Knight to a5 and now
Bishop to b5 check is an automatic here
there's there's no move other than
Bishop to b5 check here however Morphy
played the d3 in the old days you could
play in this fashion point is that if
Knight captures you will then place Iike
a D captors and c4 end you will have a
nicely protected deep on but what's the
problem with this the problem is that it
doesn't really do anything for white if
black doesn't capture on c4 but in the
game we have h6 Knight to f3 and now
black indeed captured and c4 proving
more phase point that you should play if
your opponent you know decides to play
along however in nowadays if this would
be met with E for whereas white cannot
capture on e4 because the bishop would
hang and it would cause white all sorts
of problems so we have Knight captures
on c4 the captors on c4 and Bishop to b6
Bowden
continues developing he wants the castle
Knights the c3 and there is a there are
two games the modern games I I think
from 2006 that reached this exact same
position where castles was played but
here boarding goes for a six and it is
as a moon 9 that the disposition was
never repeated again
so Murphy continues developing Bishop to
e3 might have some ideas of including c5
so born in stop set will be 6 and now h3
taking away the g4 Square from boarding
species boarding castles here and now
even a three pretty preparing before at
some point with Queen to e7 continuing
development and morphe does the same and
here already you might have some Bishop
captures on h6 ideas followed by Knight
to g5 not at the moment but it could get
a bit ugly brush up to f5 not adding
well developing a piece also it will be
very useful you can just bring it to
Jesus to h7 also at pressure c2 so it's
a it's an excellent square for the light
square bishop we have Queen to e2 more
if he decides that he wants the Queen on
e 2 instead of 1 d2 probably for the
purpose of maybe if he forest played
then the knight can be shifted to d2 and
then maybe after night was 2d - maybe we
can attack the the pond with f3
for example our K whatever his reasons
are Queen to eat you and Bishop back to
h7 by Bowden and now morphe starts his
attack on the Kings side we have g4 and
now Knight to e4 going for I'm going for
a trade here even though there's no
actual need for black to force this
trade if anything he only helps white as
black has more pieces in front of the
White King the White King is still in
the center of the board but ok Knight
captures the Bishop captures he wants to
pile on pile down on this knight on f3
route the g1 on pinning in now Queen to
f6 with a double attack on the night and
now rook to g3 for the moment the dark
square bishop cannot reach the rook so
the knight is nicely protected and again
Bowden decides to break tension he
really enjoys trading obviously Bishop
character son f3 rook captures on f3 and
quinta age for now he now has ideas of
winning the h3 pawn but morph isn't
really interested in that and morph even
offers it he plays rook to g3 now at
some point Murphy of course wants to
play g5 hopefully capturing h6 and
finish the game nicely
however he invites ephors this comes
with an attack on the rook also now look
to f3 is impossible as the pawn prevents
this and now look to g1 and now Boden
captures on h3 and Murphy says okay
that's that's your pawn I'm just gonna
Castle queenside and now I'm gonna have
both the H and the G file to use for my
attack but Boden says no he won't
there won't be an attack here happening
at all because Queen f3 like a like a
nice modern player a Bourdon grab the
pawn and now he wants to trade Queens so
Morphy of course declines Queen to d2
and now a 5 again a weird move by Bowden
a bit too slow fixing his the fixing his
pawn structure and on the Queen side
putting upon a dark square not really
sure what what the idea is but I'm sure
there were some maybe better moves but
ok King Tubby 1 and Murphy of course
doesn't want to do anything rash when
the king and queen are on the same
diagonal if the this better for example
moves Queens Bishop to f4 would would
win the Queen so of course came to be 1
always a useful prophylactic move and
now f6 not allowing more feet to bust
open the position with the g5 we've
worked h1 by morphine now that that f6
has been played you also need to realize
that the f6 Queen the f6 square was
taken away from the black Queen it was
one of the very important a retreating
square for the black Queen because here
the black Queen doesn't have all that
many squares for example if the black
Queen was somehow attacked then the
Queen has nowhere to escape okay for the
moment you have g2 but you know
something like rook the G 1 2 G 3 if the
bishop moves and it could be it could be
problematic and here if you play
something like rook 88 here you might
actually run into something like
captures captures and captures and white
would he just have a powerful attack
here for the moment
it wouldn't yield more than a draw
because of rook to e7 and now you have
to agree to a perpetual here Church
church Church church sure but it is in
the position so here Bowdoin doesn't
want to face any of that he goes King to
f7 and it is in fact the strongest move
recommended by the engine here Bowdoin
wants to shift his King all the way to
the Queen side say okay I grabbed a pawn
and I'm not interested in facing your
attack on the Kings side more if it was
rugby to g1 he also has some ideas now
he also takes away this square from the
Queen
we have Quinta East 7 and now again a
very nice idea Queen e1 and now we've
already said that the the black queen
doesn't have all that many squares so
here for example if you play Quinta F 1
followed by rook to h3 the black queen
is trapped there's there's no square for
the black Queen so here at Bowden has to
do something he goes for Bishop to f4
and now more fee and more fee tries a
nice little trick he goes to work the
age for now saying that if the bishop is
captured for example captors captures
the Queen still doesn't have anywhere to
go even though we've traded the bishop
whatever you play let's see g5 we're
gonna go route back to h1 and now
whatever you play f1 now finally rook g3
traps to the Queen
so here more if he really wants to trap
the Queen and Bowden has to try
something and here another weird move by
boring he goes rook to g8
again very unclear is the purpose of
this move but maybe we will understand
it if we continue the game it is a
mystery definitely more fee per seeds
with rook g2 h1 shifts the rook over or
over to the H file and here we have g5
this was Boden's idea but what was the
plan behind the idea it's really it's
really uncertain he gives up the h6 pawn
more he of course grabs it Boren trades
now Bishop captures F captures and now
he goes Luke 8 f8 shift the both of the
ropes ain't
game and well it just doesn't seem like
this g5 move achieved all that much well
the entire plant irrigates the g5 just
seems a bit weird
and now morphe spots that the f6 pawn is
weak and he piles up on the bone rook to
f1 attacks the Queen Queen captures and
g4 and now Queen to c3 with a nice
triple attack on the pawn here and here
Bota no longer can defend the f6 pawn so
he starts shifting the King over to the
Queen side Murphy grabs the the pawn
we have captures and f6 captures with
the Queen and f6 and now King to see it
trying to artificially castle the other
way around
we have worked the h7 by morphe and now
preparing quinta c6 and here we have
King to b8 just getting the King even
even further so you free the c8 square
for the rook to defend the c7 pawn queen
to c6 by Murphy and now look the c8
blocking this pawn and now morphe goes
for rook to d7
of course all of you want to put this
pawn and then deliver mate here I know
you guys do but if you did this then
Queen d1 check and you throw the game
yes now the King has to move black picks
up the pawn and you've achieved nothing
Morphy unlike some of you who were
thinking that it will not be tricked by
such moves so rook the d7 instead now
after d6 is pushed the rook nicely
defends the pawn so here Bohdan goes for
Queen T there's no point in guarding the
d6 square the point still is pushed to
d6 you can't do anything about it so
here he tried a queen g1 check King a to
Queen captures on e3 now he wants to
meet d6 with Queen to c5 but morphe says
that's that's perfectly fine these six
busting open the position and Queen to
c5 and here we have a very exciting
moment of course again you could never
capture here due to checkmate so Queen
c5 and well not that obviously but
morphe played Queen captures on e4 I'm
just gonna show a totally disgusting
engine line here D captures on c7 check
is winning for white but it's not at all
clear why immediately however I will
after looked after King to a seven now
comes Queen captures on e4 and the c7
pawn is off-limits
because if you capture it then you're
dead lost here White has a brilliant
move
I'm sure you even I'm sure we can even
support it but yeah feel free to pause
the video and and find why all this was
bad for black well I'll give you a
couple of seconds for those we were able
to do it
congratulations and over loading the
Queen and for those of you who just
wanna enjoy the show it's b4 of course
and now there's nothing to do here of
course if you capture on c4 then
captures you cannot capture because of
the pin and if you don't if you do
anything else let's say captures
captures still your queen is under
attack and there's no good square for
the Queen you can't keep defending the
rook you have to play something and then
just captures and mate so it is quite
quite the the disgusting engine mind the
Morphy goes for the more natural Queen
captures an e4 black still cannot
capture because of just Queen b7 mate so
we have Kings the a7 here and now
c3 by morphing we have a for not
allowing b4 here Boland realizes that it
could be somewhat problematic for the
Queen and now morphe offers a queen
trade with Queen to d5 he's up material
and he's very confident in his endgame
skills we have Queen captures see
characters a double pawn but still you
cannot capture here as the king is on a7
and here we have b5 by black again a
weird move by boarding King to b8 is of
course much much stronger you would have
to go for a trade here and after rook
captures the problem is you cannot trade
rooks even though you're up upon but the
past G point is just too far advanced
the king will not be able to reach it
for those of you who like drawing here
you can see that the King is outside the
square of the pawn so he cannot reach it
so you'd have to go up to d6 and
continue the game being up upon but with
perfect play this would would yield only
a draw for y so here
b5 was played by Borden he thought maybe
okay it's it's the same I'm just gonna
grabbed upon this way but not really
here multiple ad captures on c7 we have
King to b6 and now d6 we have g4 board
and starts advancing his past pawn but
now rook to b8 of course going for this
trade with King to b7 not allowing this
capture of again if you trade black is
just winning but here morphe is now
about to school good sir Bowden in the
ways of the rook so feel free to pause
the video once again and win this game
for white while I give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations on pushing the
pawn immediately and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show its d7
rook to e8 foul by d7 is also winning
but it's way cooler if you did it the
way more fitted so the point is rook
captures on c7 and now you sacrifice the
rook rook the C rook to b8 check King
captures and now you bring a queen into
the game and it was in this position
unmoved 50 that Samuel Standage Bowden
resigned the game and yet another
excellent victory for poor Charles
Murphy upon arriving in in London so
really impressive stuff I really enjoyed
the game especially that d3 align to the
two Knights defense something you will
not see today so I thought it was a
really nice and the game did have its
moments with a couple of weird moves
from Bouldin but yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Keith's tester now Pablo Mohan
Eric neat in our Christian unit and
mohanty Booker Putnam for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Morphy saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day